- Bem-vindo a Entendendo
Informação e Computação Quântica.
Meu nome é John Watrous, e sou o diretor técnico
de Educação Quântica da IBM.
O objetivo desta série é fornecer a você
uma compreensão sólida da informação e computação quântica, e isso significa entrar
nos detalhes técnicos
da informação quântica e ver como a computação quântica realmente funciona, o que ela pode fazer e o que não pode.
Se você ainda não assistiu
ao vídeo de visão geral desta série, eu te encorajo a conferir.
Naquele vídeo, você encontrará informações sobre que tipo de preparação de fundo
é recomendada para esta série, bem como um esboço dos
tópicos a serem abordados.
Além disso, certifique-se de conferir
o livro didático do Qiskit, que aborda o mesmo
material que esta série de vídeos em formato escrito,
e também inclui
componentes interativos e interfaces com hardware e software projetados para ajudá-lo a entender melhor
a informação e computação quântica. Você encontrará links para o vídeo de visão geral e o livro didático do Qiskit
na descrição.
Esta é a aula um da
unidade um da série.
A unidade um cobre os fundamentos
da informação quântica, e na primeira aula desta unidade, vamos nos concentrar em como
a informação quântica funciona
para sistemas simples, o que significa que temos
apenas um sistema físico ou um dispositivo de algum tipo que
armazena informação quântica
e estamos considerando como esse
único sistema ou dispositivo funciona isoladamente.
Na aula seguinte a esta, vamos discutir como
a informação quântica funciona quando temos múltiplos sistemas, e isso nos permitirá
descrever conceitos interessantes
e importantes, como algoritmos quânticos que fazem uso de múltiplos qubits
e protocolos quânticos
envolvendo múltiplos indivíduos que processam informação quântica e a transmitem de um lado
para o outro.
Mas antes de entrar nessas discussões, faz sentido começar com o
contexto comparativamente simples de um único sistema isolado,
em parte porque é bom começar pelo simples, mas também porque, como veremos, a descrição de como
a informação quântica funciona
para sistemas simples isolados leva de forma muito natural e lógica à descrição de como
para múltiplos sistemas.
Aqui está uma breve visão geral da aula.
Vamos começar discutindo
informação clássica.
O objetivo desta aula não é explicar como
a informação clássica funciona; é explicar como
a informação quântica funciona,
mas para explicar como
a informação quântica funciona, é muito útil começar
com a informação clássica e usá-la como um
ponto de referência familiar
quando discutirmos informação quântica.
Em nível matemático, a informação quântica e a clássica têm descrições bastante semelhantes, com algumas diferenças fundamentais, é claro.
Na verdade, a informação quântica
não é separada da informação clássica.
É uma extensão da
informação clássica.
A realidade é,
pelo menos na minha visão, que você realmente não consegue
entender a informação quântica se não entende
a informação clássica,
então começar com a informação clássica
faz sentido.
Espero que este
conteúdo seja familiar para alguns espectadores, mas mesmo que seja familiar para você, não recomendo que você o pule.
Além de destacar os aspectos da informação clássica que são mais relevantes para
entender a informação quântica, vamos introduzir a
notação de Dirac nesta parte,
que é uma forma padrão
que vamos usar para descrever vetores e
matrizes ao longo da série.
Acontece que a notação de Dirac não é
específica para informação quântica.
Ela pode igualmente ser usada no contexto da informação clássica, bem como em muitos outros contextos onde vetores e matrizes surgem.
Em seguida, passaremos para a informação quântica e, especificamente, vamos
discutir a representação de estados quânticos como vetores,
um tipo simples de medição chamado medição de base padrão e operações unitárias, que descrevem mudanças discretas no tempo
em sistemas quânticos.
Tudo no contexto
de sistemas simples.
Antes de começarmos com a aula em si, será útil esclarecer que existem na verdade duas descrições
da informação quântica: a descrição simplificada, que é no que vamos nos
concentrar nesta aula
e ao longo desta primeira unidade, e a descrição geral, que é abordada em uma unidade posterior, especificamente na
terceira unidade da série.
A descrição simplificada,
fiel ao seu nome, é mais simples e é
tipicamente aprendida primeiro.
Na descrição simplificada, como já sugeri, os estados quânticos são representados por vetores e as operações são representadas
por matrizes unitárias.
Essa descrição da informação quântica é suficiente para uma compreensão
da maioria dos algoritmos quânticos, por exemplo,
então não é uma simplificação excessiva; é a coisa real.
No entanto, conforme
descobriremos ao longo do caminho, ela tem algumas limitações.
Por exemplo, se queremos
modelar os efeitos do ruído em sistemas quânticos, essa descrição acaba sendo insuficiente.
A descrição geral, por
outro lado, é mais geral e, em última análise, é mais
poderosa em sentido matemático.
Nessa descrição, os estados quânticos são representados por uma classe especial de matrizes
chamadas matrizes de densidade,
e uma classe mais geral de
medições e operações pode ser descrita, incluindo
ruído, por exemplo.
É totalmente consistente com
a descrição simplificada e, de fato, você pode essencialmente ver
a descrição simplificada
como um caso especial da
descrição geral, e ela também inclui a informação clássica como um caso especial.
É também realmente muito
bela na forma como tudo funciona, então encorajo fortemente você a aprender sobre essa descrição geral
quando for o momento certo, mas a descrição simplificada é o ponto de partida mais natural, e é isso que vamos fazer.
Vamos começar falando sobre informação clássica com foco nos aspectos
da informação clássica que são mais relevantes
para a informação quântica
e a forma como ela é
descrita matematicamente.
Imagine que temos um
sistema físico ou um dispositivo de algum tipo que armazena informação.
Vamos dar a esse sistema o nome X, mas não há
nada de especial nesse nome.
Poderíamos usar qualquer outro
nome se preferirmos, mas apenas para escolher um nome,
vamos chamar o sistema de X.
Vamos fazer uma suposição sobre X, que é que existe um
conjunto finito de estados clássicos que X pode estar
em qualquer dado momento.
Aqui, quando me refiro a um estado clássico, quero dizer uma configuração do sistema que pode ser reconhecida e
descrita sem ambiguidade
sem qualquer incerteza ou erro.
Na verdade, isso é algo que você pode pensar intuitivamente. Em nível matemático, simplesmente definimos o
conjunto de estados clássicos,
escolhemos da forma que quisermos ou da maneira que melhor
descreve o dispositivo com que estamos trabalhando.
Vamos dar o nome sigma a
esse conjunto de estados clássicos, e novamente, deixa eu enfatizar
que estamos assumindo que sigma é um conjunto finito.
O conjunto de estados clássicos
desse sistema X não é infinitamente grande como
o conjunto de todos os números naturais.
É finito, e isso é apenas
uma suposição que estamos fazendo.
Por exemplo, pode ser que X seja um bit, caso em que o conjunto de estados clássicos é o conjunto contendo dois
elementos: zero e um.
Às vezes nos referimos a este
conjunto como o alfabeto binário.
Outro exemplo é que X é
um dado comum de seis lados, caso em que os estados clássicos são os números de um a seis.
Claro, estamos falando
de uma abstração aqui.
Um dado de seis lados real pode
ter muitos atributos diferentes, como sua posição precisa, sua orientação,
sua temperatura, e assim por diante. Mas com relação à informação que é mais tipicamente relevante quando estamos falando sobre um dado de seis lados,
os estados clássicos são
os números de um a seis indicados pelo número de pontos no lado do dado que está voltado para cima.
Se X é um interruptor em um
ventilador elétrico padrão que você pode ter em sua casa, então talvez os estados clássicos
sejam as configurações alto,
médio, baixo e desligado.
Esses são apenas exemplos. Poderíamos imaginar sistemas tendo conjuntos de estados clássicos
diferentes desses, mas esperamos que eles transmitam a ideia
de que essa noção de estado clássico é algo que deve ser
familiar e pode ser entendido em termos simples e intuitivos.
Matematicamente falando, o conjunto de estados clássicos
é apenas um conjunto finito, e claro, esse conjunto também deve
ser não vazio.
Tem que haver pelo menos
um estado clássico em que o sistema possa estar, e tem que haver pelo menos dois estados clássicos
se o sistema for ser útil para armazenar informação.
Agora, em algumas situações, podemos saber que X está
em algum estado específico, mas em muitas situações,
que surgem no contexto
do processamento de informação, pode haver incerteza sobre o estado clássico de um
sistema em um determinado momento
de modo que cada possível estado clássico tenha alguma probabilidade associada a ele.
Por exemplo, se X é um bit, então talvez X esteja no estado clássico zero
com probabilidade três quartos e esteja no estado um
com probabilidade um quarto.
Vamos nos referir a isso
como um estado probabilístico, e poderíamos expressar
esse estado probabilístico como você vê aqui,
simplesmente indicando quais
são as probabilidades para os diferentes estados clássicos.
Uma forma mais sucinta de expressar
esse estado probabilístico é por um vetor; especificamente, a representação
que você vê aqui
é um vetor coluna, e esse vetor indica
quais são as probabilidades para os dois possíveis estados clássicos.
Para ser mais específico, a primeira entrada indica
qual é a probabilidade de X estar no estado zero, e a segunda entrada nos diz qual é a probabilidade
de o sistema estar no estado um. Esta é simplesmente a forma natural de ordenar o alfabeto binário,
ou pelo menos, é a forma que
somos treinados a fazer isso: com zero primeiro e um depois.
Daqui para frente, vamos usar
o termo vetor de probabilidade para indicar um vetor como este.
Especificamente, é um vetor cujas entradas são todas
números reais não negativos e onde a soma das
entradas é igual a um,
então faz sentido
pensar nessas entradas como sendo probabilidades.
Neste exemplo, há apenas duas entradas porque há apenas dois
estados clássicos do sistema de que estamos falando,
mas em geral, pode haver
qualquer número de entradas, sendo que
há uma entrada para cada estado clássico
de qualquer sistema de que estejamos falando.
Vamos continuar
discutindo informação clássica, vetores de probabilidade e
assim por diante em um instante, mas primeiro, será muito útil
introduzir uma notação
para descrever vetores conhecida como notação de Dirac.
Na verdade, esta é apenas a primeira
parte da notação de Dirac.
Há alguns outros
aspectos da notação de Dirac que veremos um pouco
mais tarde na aula.
Essa notação será
bastante central para a forma como descrevemos a informação quântica, então é essencial
entender como ela funciona,
mas felizmente, é muito simples e realmente não tem
nada de específico para informação quântica,
então podemos introduzi-la agora
no contexto familiar da informação clássica.
Como antes, assumimos que temos um conjunto sigma de
estados clássicos de algum sistema, e vamos assumir
que temos uma ordenação
desses estados clássicos, assim como nos referimos a uma
ordenação do alfabeto binário
no exemplo anterior. Outra forma de dizer isso
é que os elementos de sigma são colocados em correspondência
com o inteiro
de um até quantos
elementos estão contidos em sigma, que é o que esta notação aqui com duas barras ao redor de sigma significa.
Esse é o número de
elementos no conjunto sigma.
Então há um primeiro estado,
um segundo estado, e assim por diante.
A ordenação ou
correspondência específica que escolhemos não vai importar muito.
O que é realmente importante é
que temos uma ordenação e nos mantemos nela.
Para muitos conjuntos de estados clássicos
que encontraremos, haverá uma ordenação padrão, assim como temos com
o alfabeto binário,
e se não houver uma ordenação padrão, podemos simplesmente escolher uma.
Mas seja como for, o entendimento é que nos mantemos nela.
Agora, aqui está a notação
que está sendo introduzida.
Para qualquer escolha de um estado clássico a
do nosso conjunto sigma, escrevemos isso aqui, que é lido como ket a,
para significar o vetor coluna
que tem um 1 na entrada correspondente a a e um zero para todas as outras entradas.
Por exemplo, se voltarmos
ao alfabeto binário, que, como você pode ter adivinhado, é um exemplo muito importante
ao qual voltaremos repetidamente. Então ket zero e ket um são os vetores que são definidos aqui.
Ket zero é o vetor
que tem um 1 na entrada correspondente ao estado clássico zero, que é a primeira entrada,
e um zero para todas as outras entradas, e neste caso, há
apenas uma outra entrada.
Da mesma forma, ket um é
este vetor aqui onde temos um 1 na
entrada correspondente a um,
que é a segunda entrada, e um zero para todas as outras entradas, que, novamente, é apenas uma entrada.
Aqui está outro exemplo. Neste exemplo, temos um
conjunto de estados clássicos sigma correspondente aos quatro naipes
de um baralho padrão de cartas de jogar: paus, ouros, copas e espadas.
Neste caso, não há uma
ordenação universalmente acordada desses naipes.
Para muitos jogos de cartas, não há ordenação alguma. São apenas quatro naipes diferentes e é isso que importa, e há diferentes jogos de cartas que ordenam esses naipes
de formas diferentes, mas não importa realmente.
Podemos simplesmente escolher uma
ordenação como a que você vê aqui.
Esta é a ordenação alfabética de acordo com os nomes desses quatro naipes escritos em inglês,
Assumindo que escolhemos
esta ordenação em particular, então definimos esses quatro vetores: ket clubs, ket diamonds,
ket hearts e ket spades
como você vê aqui, e esses vetores correspondem
à descrição geral que você vê lá em cima.
Dado que escolhemos
esta ordenação em particular para esses quatro naipes.
Podemos fazer a mesma coisa para qualquer conjunto de estados clássicos
que escolhermos.
Tendo em mente que conjunto de estados clássicos
sempre significa conjunto finito e não vazio.
Vetores dessa forma são
chamados de vetores de base padrão, e é um fato muito básico sobre vetores que todo vetor pode ser
expresso de forma única
como uma combinação linear
de vetores de base padrão.
Por exemplo, voltando ao exemplo de um momento atrás, o vetor de probabilidade
que vimos pode ser expresso
como você vê aqui. É basicamente apenas uma forma alternativa de expressar vetores
que será muito útil por várias razões daqui para frente.
E com essa notação agora em mãos, vamos voltar à discussão
da informação clássica e estados probabilísticos em particular.
E vamos considerar o que acontece
quando medimos um sistema enquanto ele está em algum estado probabilístico.
Normalmente não nos referimos
a uma medição ou ao ato de medir
algo em um contexto clássico, mas o termo faz sentido.
Em essência, quando falamos
sobre medir o sistema X neste contexto, queremos dizer apenas que olhamos para ele e reconhecemos qualquer estado em que esteja.
Claro, quando olhamos para o sistema, não vemos um estado probabilístico; vemos um estado clássico,
e o estado clássico
específico que vemos é aquele que podemos
imaginar ser escolhido aleatoriamente de acordo com as probabilidades.
Agora, você pode objetar em
bases filosóficas à ideia de que o estado clássico que vemos é de alguma forma escolhido aleatoriamente
no momento em que medimos ou olhamos para o sistema; o sistema simplesmente estava em algum estado clássico
específico o tempo todo
e simplesmente aconteceu de
aprendermos qual era o estado, mas para fins de pensar sobre o
arcabouço matemático com que estamos trabalhando,
é ok pensar dessa forma e fazer isso nos permitirá traçar um paralelo com
a informação quântica um pouco mais tarde.
Vamos supor que o
estado clássico que vemos é o estado clássico a, que pode ser qualquer estado em nosso conjunto sigma.
Isso muda o estado probabilístico
de X em geral, pelo menos do nosso ponto de vista.
As probabilidades não têm mais
nenhum significado porque agora sabemos qual
é o estado clássico de X.
É a, e não há mais
nenhuma incerteza sobre isso.
Então diríamos agora
que a probabilidade de o sistema estar no estado a é um.
Sabemos disso porque acabamos de olhar para ele e vimos que o estado clássico é a, então o novo estado probabilístico de X é um
no qual a probabilidade de
estar no estado clássico a é igual a um.
E esse estado probabilístico é representado pelo
vetor de probabilidade ket a.
Temos um 1 na entrada correspondente ao estado clássico a e um zero em todas as outras entradas.
Por exemplo, se considerarmos
novamente a situação em que X é um bit e temos o mesmo
estado probabilístico de antes,
então se medirmos X, podemos imaginar que uma
transição acontece.
Com probabilidade três quartos, vemos o estado clássico zero, e ao medir, fazemos a transição para ket zero
sendo nosso estado probabilístico,
e com probabilidade um quarto, fazemos a transição para ket um.
Você pode pensar nisso como uma transição de conhecimento, se preferir, em vez de uma
transição física real,
mas o que é importante para
esta aula é reconhecer como a matemática funciona.
É meio trivial, na verdade, mas ao reconhecer essa trivialidade, a descrição análoga
para o contexto quântico
pode parecer um pouco menos misteriosa.
Uma nota final é que para outra pessoa que não viu
qual era o estado clássico de X quando o medimos,
o estado probabilístico
naturalmente não mudaria como resultado de termos medido.
Tudo bem. Diferentes indivíduos podem
ter conhecimentos diferentes de um determinado sistema e correspondentemente escolher
estados probabilísticos diferentes
para representar seu
conhecimento desse sistema.
Na última parte desta discussão sobre informação clássica, falaremos sobre operações clássicas que podem ser realizadas em um sistema,
começando com operações determinísticas.
Quando realizamos uma operação em um sistema, seu estado geralmente muda como resultado, e neste contexto, a palavra determinístico significa
que o resultado de realizar
a operação depende inteiramente de qualquer estado clássico
em que o sistema estava
antes de a operação ser realizada.
Em outras palavras, não há
elemento de acaso quando uma operação determinística
é realizada, então não há aleatoriedade
ou incerteza envolvida.
Em termos matemáticos, operações determinísticas
são descritas por funções.
Toda função f da forma
que você vê aqui, o que significa que tanto a entrada quanto a saída da função
correspondem a elementos do
nosso conjunto de estados clássicos sigma, descreve uma operação determinística.
O estado clássico a é
transformado no estado f de a para cada escolha de um estado a.
Para toda função f dessa forma, haverá sempre uma matriz única M satisfazendo esta condição
que você vê aqui,
e é que, ao multiplicar
M pelo vetor ket a, obtemos o vetor ket f de a,
e isso é válido para toda
escolha de um estado clássico a.
Não é muito difícil escrever
uma descrição explícita de M dada qualquer função f
desta forma que escolhemos.
Ela sempre terá exatamente
um 1 em cada coluna, com todas as outras entradas iguais a zero.
E aqui está a fórmula. A entrada b, a de M é igual a um se b é igual a f de a
e caso contrário é igual a zero, e com isso, queremos dizer
que esta é a entrada de M cuja linha corresponde a b
e cuja coluna corresponde a a.
Veremos alguns exemplos em um instante, e veremos por que essa fórmula funciona.
Agora, pode não estar claro por que gostaríamos de pegar uma função e expressá-la como uma matriz como esta,
mas faz sentido fazer isso. Uma das razões, e talvez seja a razão principal, é que, se temos um sistema
em um estado probabilístico
e realizamos uma operação determinística
nesse sistema, então o estado probabilístico resultante pode ser obtido
por multiplicação matriz-vetor, ou seja, se nosso sistema está
em um estado probabilístico
representado por
algum vetor de probabilidade v e realizamos a operação determinística descrita por M
nesse sistema, então o estado probabilístico resultante será dado por M vezes v.
Aqui, aliás, esta seta com uma pequena
barra é apenas uma notação comum em matemática para indicar como uma
coisa é mapeada para
ou transformada em outra coisa. Você poderia usar apenas uma seta comum, mas esta é convencional
e é reconhecível e talvez seja um pouco mais específica do que apenas uma seta, que pode significar muitas coisas diferentes.
Agora vamos dar uma olhada em um exemplo ou uma coleção de exemplos, na verdade.
Vamos considerar o que acontece quando tomamos nosso conjunto de estados clássicos sigma como sendo, novamente, o alfabeto binário.
Não há muitas funções diferentes da forma que estivemos discutindo quando esse é nosso conjunto de estados clássicos e, para ser mais preciso, há apenas quatro
funções dessa forma.
Aqui, essas quatro funções são descritas por suas chamadas tabelas de valores.
A primeira tabela descreve
a primeira função, que chamamos de f1.
Para cada entrada possível à esquerda, listamos a
saída correspondente à direita, então f1 de zero é igual a zero,
e f1 de um é, novamente, igual a zero, o que quer dizer que f1 é
a função constante zero.
Ela sempre tem o valor zero.
A segunda função f2
é a função identidade.
A saída é sempre igual à entrada, como você pode ver na segunda tabela.
A terceira função f3 é
descrita pela terceira tabela.
f3 de zero é igual a um, e f3 de um é igual a zero.
Esta função é mais
conhecida como a função NOT ou negação lógica.
Às vezes também a chamamos de inversão de bit porque ela inverte zero
para um e um para zero.
A última função f4 é,
novamente, uma função constante assim como a primeira, mas esta é a função constante um
porque sempre tem o valor um.
E essas são as únicas quatro funções do alfabeto binário para si mesmo.
Aqui estão as quatro matrizes que correspondem a essas quatro funções, descritas pela
fórmula de antes,
que você pode ver aqui, e se quiser, pode pausar o vídeo e verificar isso.
Lembre-se apenas que com matrizes, a ordem dos índices é sempre linhas primeiro, colunas depois.
Então a entrada b, a corresponde
à linha b e à coluna a, ou a linha que corresponde
ao estado clássico b
e a coluna que corresponde
ao estado clássico a.
Então, por exemplo, se olharmos
para a primeira função, temos que f1 de zero é igual a zero
e, correspondentemente, a
entrada zero, zero de M1 é igual a um.
Bem, a entrada um, zero
que está aqui é igual a zero, e você pode fazer a mesma coisa para o caso
onde a entrada é igual a um e, da mesma forma, para as
outras três funções.
Você também pode verificar que esta
fórmula de antes é verdadeira e pode ir um a um por todas as diferentes
possibilidades para verificar isso.
E na verdade, se você pensar sobre o modo que a
multiplicação de matrizes funciona, você pode simplesmente visualizar isso.
Quando você multiplica uma matriz por um vetor de base padrão como este, pode imaginar que
você está pegando a entrada
e colocando-a no topo de uma das matrizes em qualquer coluna que corresponda
ao estado clássico
dentro do ket, e a saída que você
obtém é simplesmente aquela coluna como um vetor de probabilidade.
Então, por exemplo, M3 multiplicado por ket
zero dá a você zero, um
como vetor de probabilidade, que é ket um.
M3 multiplicado por ket
um dá a você um, zero, que é ket zero, e assim por diante.
Vamos discutir operações em
estados probabilísticos mais daqui a pouco, mas primeiro, vamos introduzir a segunda parte da notação de Dirac.
Isso vai ser útil
para falar sobre operações e pensar sobre elas como matrizes, e também vai ser uma ferramenta padrão
que vamos continuar a usar daqui para frente. A configuração é exatamente como era antes.
Temos qualquer conjunto de estados clássicos sigma com que estejamos trabalhando e assumimos que temos alguma forma de
ordenar esses estados clássicos.
Em seguida, escrevemos isso
que você vê aqui, onde desta vez a
barra angular está à esquerda em vez de à direita, para significar
o vetor linha tendo um 1
na entrada que
corresponde a a e um zero para todas as outras entradas correspondendo a todos os
outros estados clássicos.
Então a diferença entre
esta coisa e ket a é que esta é um vetor linha e
ket a é um vetor coluna,
mas caso contrário, os vetores
são definidos de forma similar.
Lemos isto como bra a; não tenho certeza se isso é suposto ser engraçado, mas a ideia é que os nomes bra e ket
são duas metades da palavra bracket, e teremos mais a dizer
sobre isso em um instante.
Mas primeiro, vamos dar uma olhada
em um exemplo muito rápido.
Para o alfabeto binário, temos que bra zero é
este vetor linha aqui, análogo a ket a,
exceto que é um vetor linha
em vez de um vetor coluna, e bra um é este vetor aqui.
Agora em geral, se multiplicarmos um vetor linha
por um vetor coluna, pensando neles como matrizes
que por acaso têm apenas
uma linha ou apenas uma coluna, então obtemos uma matriz um por um, que podemos pensar
como sendo um escalar.
Aqui, aliás, você deve
pensar nesses asteriscos como representando números arbitrários.
Em particular, se
multiplicarmos o vetor linha bra a pelo vetor coluna ket b,
então há duas coisas que podem acontecer.
Uma é que a e b são iguais, então são o mesmo estado clássico, caso em que os uns ficam alinhados
e o produto será igual a um; ou pode ser o caso
em que a e b são diferentes,
e então os uns não ficam alinhados e o produto é igual a zero.
Uma forma simples de expressar
essas observações é como se vê aqui.
E só para manter as coisas organizadas, escrevemos este produto assim, com apenas uma barra no meio, e significa exatamente a mesma
coisa que isto aqui.
E agora você pode ver como o
bra e o ket se juntam para formar um bracket, que também é chamado de produto interno,
e isso é algo
bastante importante sobre o qual voltaremos
na aula número três.
Multiplicar um vetor coluna
por um vetor linha, por outro lado, nos dá uma matriz como você pode ver aqui.
Então, por exemplo, voltando
mais uma vez ao alfabeto binário, se multiplicarmos ket zero por bra zero,
obtemos esta matriz aqui, e podemos ir pelas
outras possibilidades para ver o que acontece.
Ket zero vezes bra um nos dá
esta matriz aqui, onde o um se moveu
para esta posição.
Ket um, bra zero parece assim, e aqui está ket um, bra um.
O que vemos acontecendo é que há apenas um único um em uma matriz que do contrário é toda de zeros, e a posição desse um
é determinada por quais
estados clássicos escolhemos no bra e no ket.
Mais precisamente, e
isso é verdade em geral, para qualquer escolha de um conjunto de estados clássicos, a matriz que obtemos multiplicando ket a por bra b
é a matriz com um 1 na entrada a, b e um zero para todas as outras entradas.
E agora que temos tanto a
primeira quanto a segunda parte da notação de Dirac, temos uma ferramenta muito útil para conectar operações com matrizes.
Então vamos voltar brevemente
às operações determinísticas e lembrar que um pouco
antes na aula,
foi afirmado que para toda função f
desta forma aqui, temos uma operação determinística que transforma a em f de a
para cada estado clássico possível a. E dissemos que para
qualquer função assim, há sempre uma matriz única M que age assim
em estados de base padrão.
Usando a notação de Dirac, agora podemos facilmente expressar essa matriz como você vê aqui,
e podemos ver como às vezes
é possível trabalhar com matrizes inteiramente
dentro do arcabouço da notação de Dirac
sem nunca converter explicitamente
para vetores e matrizes, ou seja, retângulos preenchidos com números.
Neste caso, podemos verificar que a
fórmula requerida é verdadeira multiplicando M por ket a.
Substituímos nossa
expressão para M assim, e podemos remover os parênteses e juntar o bra
b com o ket a assim.
E isso porque a
multiplicação de matrizes é linear, neste caso, no primeiro argumento, e é associativa, então podemos remover os parênteses.
E agora, lembrando que temos um a fixo sobre o qual estamos falando enquanto somamos sobre todas as
possíveis escolhas de b,
este bracket aqui vai
ser sempre igual a zero quando b não é igual a a, então não haverá
nenhuma contribuição para a soma,
e quando b é igual a a, o bracket será igual a um e então ficaremos com
este único termo aqui.
Essa é a fórmula que queríamos e temos assim uma forma muito boa e simples de expressar uma função como uma matriz.
Além das operações determinísticas, também temos operações que
elas mesmas introduzem aleatoriedade ou incerteza sobre o
estado clássico de um sistema.
Usamos o termo operação probabilística para significar operações como esta, e para ser preciso, quando dizemos operação probabilística,
queremos dizer operações que
podem introduzir aleatoriedade, então operações determinísticas são na verdade um caso especial
de operações probabilísticas
que simplesmente não introduzem
nenhuma aleatoriedade.
Aqui está um exemplo simples onde
alguma aleatoriedade é introduzida.
Esta é uma operação em um único bit. A forma como funciona é que, se o estado clássico
do bit é zero,
então nada acontece. O bit fica como zero, mas se o estado clássico
do bit é um, então a operação inverte o bit para zero
com probabilidade igual a 1/2.
Não há nenhum nome especial
para esta operação, pelo menos que eu saiba.
É apenas um exemplo, mas você poderia imaginar realizar
esta operação em um bit.
Assim como operações determinísticas, operações probabilísticas podem
ser representadas por matrizes e suas ações em estados probabilísticos
são dadas por multiplicação matriz-vetor, assim como antes.
Desta vez, não é necessariamente o caso que as matrizes têm exatamente um 1 em cada coluna e zeros caso contrário.
Operações probabilísticas são
mais geralmente representadas por matrizes estocásticas.
Essas são matrizes cujas entradas são todas
números reais não negativos e onde as entradas em
cada coluna somam um.
Isso é equivalente a dizer
que matrizes estocásticas são matrizes onde cada coluna
forma um vetor de probabilidade.
Isso faz sentido quando você pensa sobre
a ação de uma matriz em um vetor de base padrão.
Você considera qualquer
estado clássico que quiser e imagina colocar esse estado no topo da matriz em qualquer coluna que corresponda
a esse estado clássico,
e aquela coluna te diz qual
é o estado probabilístico que sai como vetor de probabilidade.
A operação probabilística
no nosso exemplo, por exemplo, é descrita por esta matriz aqui.
Se realizarmos esta operação
no estado clássico zero, então o estado probabilístico que obtemos é dado pela primeira coluna,
que é, novamente, o estado clássico zero ou, equivalentemente, o estado probabilístico onde zero ocorre com probabilidade um.
Se, em vez disso, realizarmos esta operação no estado clássico um, então efetivamente apenas aleatorizamos o bit e, correspondentemente, obtemos
este vetor de probabilidade aqui
onde a probabilidade para
cada um dos estados possíveis é igual a 1/2.
Em geral, se realizarmos esta operação em qualquer estado probabilístico, então o efeito é essencialmente
apenas uma média ponderada entre as duas colunas
porque é assim que a multiplicação matriz-vetor
funciona.
É linear, então simplesmente fazemos a média dos dois
resultados possíveis adequadamente.
Quando pensamos sobre operações probabilísticas
dessa forma, é natural pensar sobre
elas como potencialmente introduzindo ou injetando aleatoriedade.
Podemos simplesmente ler as colunas uma a uma e podemos ver a aleatoriedade
que elas introduzem para cada estado clássico possível.
Você também pode pensar sobre
operações probabilísticas de uma forma ligeiramente diferente, que é que elas são escolhas aleatórias de operações determinísticas.
Por exemplo, no nosso exemplo, podemos pensar sobre esta operação como sendo equivalente a
jogar uma moeda justa
e realizar a
função constante zero ou a função identidade
cada uma com probabilidade 1/2,
e você pode ver isso refletido
aqui por esta equação.
Isso é sempre possível para
qualquer operação probabilística, e é bastante intuitivo.
Se você fez escolhas aleatórias
como parte de algum processo, você sempre poderia imaginar fazer essas escolhas aleatórias com antecedência
e então codificar essas
escolhas em alguma coleção de operações determinísticas.
Às vezes é bastante útil pensar sobre operações probabilísticas
dessa forma, e veremos um exemplo
disso mais adiante em algumas aulas.
A última coisa a dizer
sobre informação clássica para esta aula diz respeito à composição
de operações probabilísticas, que significa apenas realizar
uma após a outra.
Vamos supor que temos
algum sistema chamado X e M1 a Mn são matrizes estocásticas representando operações probabilísticas
em X.
Imagine primeiro que temos
um vetor de probabilidade v, que representa um estado probabilístico
de X em algum momento, e então primeiro aplicamos
a primeira operação probabilística a X, que é representada pela matriz M1, e então aplicamos a segunda
operação probabilística,
que é representada por M2.
Se fizermos isso, então o
vetor de probabilidade que obtemos após aplicar apenas a primeira
operação é M1 vezes v,
e então quando aplicamos
a segunda operação, o vetor de probabilidade resultante é M2 multiplicado por qualquer vetor que obtivemos
após aplicar M1. Então fica assim.
Agora, a multiplicação de matrizes
é uma operação associativa, o que significa que não importa onde colocamos esses parênteses.
Poderíamos igualmente
colocar os parênteses assim.
Isso é muito simples, mas também é interessante porque revela que podemos
pensar sobre a operação onde primeiro aplicamos M1
e depois aplicamos M2
como uma única operação.
Em outras palavras, a
operação probabilística que obtemos compondo a primeira e
a segunda operação probabilística é representada pelo
produto de matrizes M2 vezes M1,
e essa é a mesma operação independentemente do estado probabilístico com que começamos.
Não precisamos saber nada sobre o vetor de probabilidade v para pensar ou descrever
essa operação composta.
Note que a ordem
aqui é M2 à esquerda e M1 à direita, o que é porque a
matriz à direita, M1,
é a que é
multiplicada pelo vetor v, ao passo que M2 é multiplicada
por qualquer vetor que obtemos após multiplicar por M1.
Portanto, sempre devemos ter em mente que a ordem em algum
sentido fica invertida.
A operação realizada
primeiro é a que fica à direita e a operação que é realizada por último ou, neste caso, em segundo lugar,
é a que fica à esquerda.
Se não pararmos na segunda operação e aplicarmos todas elas em
ordem, começando com a primeira e terminando com a última, que é Mn,
então a composição de todas
essas operações juntas é dada por este produto
que você vê aqui,
e você vê que a ordenação
mais uma vez é invertida exatamente pela mesma razão de antes.
Então, em suma, as composições
de operações probabilísticas são representadas por produtos
de matrizes estocásticas que as representam.
Tendo em mente que esta é
a ordenação das matrizes no produto.
Você sempre obterá uma matriz estocástica tomando um produto de
matrizes estocásticas como esta, e às vezes expressamos esse fato
dizendo que as matrizes
estocásticas são fechadas sob multiplicação, e a forma que você
pode pensar sobre isso é que você não pode sair do
conjunto de matrizes estocásticas
multiplicando-as porque o conjunto é fechado.
Voltando à
ordenação das matrizes neste produto, é importante notar que a
ordenação realmente importa.
A multiplicação de matrizes não é comutativa. Se você mudar a ordenação das
matrizes no produto, pode mudar o resultado,
e não precisamos olhar mais longe do que as operações determinísticas para ver isso.
Aqui está um exemplo simples de
duas matrizes estocásticas, ambas representando
operações determinísticas onde a ordenação importa.
M1 representa a função constante zero. Assumindo que estamos imaginando que essas duas operações são em bits, assim como no exemplo anterior.
M2 representa a operação NOT
ou inversão de bit.
Se você realizar M1 primeiro
e depois M2, o resultado é esta matriz aqui, que representa a
função constante um.
Se você definir um bit como zero
e depois invertê-lo, é a mesma coisa que simplesmente
defini-lo como um.
Por outro lado, se você realizar M2 primeiro
e depois M1, este é o resultado aqui,
e isso faz sentido porque se você inverter um bit
e depois defini-lo como zero, é a mesma coisa que
simplesmente defini-lo como zero.
Não importou que você o tenha invertido. Obviamente, essas duas
matrizes não são iguais, e então temos um exemplo muito
simples revelando
que a ordem importa. Claro, isso não é surpreendente.
Todos sabemos que a ordem em que
as operações são realizadas importa, ou pelo menos pode importar.
Por exemplo, se você acender um
fósforo e depois soprar, o resultado é muito diferente
de soprar no fósforo primeiro
e depois acendê-lo. Neste ponto, falamos bastante
sobre informação clássica e agora é finalmente hora de
discutir informação quântica.
E o que descobriremos é que,
matematicamente falando, a informação quântica funciona
de uma forma muito similar à informação clássica
com algumas diferenças fundamentais.
A primeira diferença fundamental
está logo no início: como definimos um estado, neste caso, um estado quântico de um sistema,
e há um sentido em que essa única escolha, como
definimos um estado quântico, determina em grande parte como
a informação quântica funciona.
Também vamos definir como
medições e operações funcionam, e na próxima aula, vamos discutir como
a informação quântica funciona não apenas para sistemas simples,
mas para múltiplos sistemas,
mas essas coisas de fato
seguem de forma bastante natural, uma vez que a noção de estado quântico de um único sistema
isolado tenha sido estabelecida.
Aqui está a definição. Um estado quântico de um sistema é representado por um vetor coluna cujos índices são colocados
em correspondência com os
estados clássicos desse sistema.
Então estamos assumindo aqui que
o sistema de que estamos falando tem algum conjunto de estados clássicos, assim como quando falamos
sobre informação clássica
e estados probabilísticos. As entradas em um vetor de estado quântico são números complexos, em oposição ao caso probabilístico
onde as entradas são
números reais não negativos.
E desta vez, a soma dos valores absolutos
ao quadrado das entradas deve ser igual a um, em oposição à soma ser igual a um
como temos no caso probabilístico.
Os números complexos que aparecem
em um vetor de estado quântico são às vezes chamados de amplitudes e desempenham um papel similar às probabilidades,
mas não são probabilidades e não têm a
mesma interpretação.
Agora, não posso te dar uma boa razão para que os estados quânticos
devam ser definidos assim, exceto dizer que
os físicos descobriram
que essa definição
é fisicamente relevante e nos permite descrever e modelar
sistemas mecânicos quânticos.
Em outras palavras, escolhemos essa definição
porque ela funciona, não porque há
razões particulares pelas quais os estados quânticos devem
ser definidos assim.
Com relação à
matemática desta noção de estado quântico, o primeiro passo para entendê-la e trabalhar com ela é
lembrar esta definição
para a norma euclidiana de um vetor, que você pode pensar geometricamente como o comprimento de um vetor, assim como pensaria sobre o comprimento
de um vetor real bidimensional se o desenhasse em um pedaço
de papel como uma seta partindo da origem da maneira habitual.
Especificamente, se temos um
vetor coluna v como este, que assumimos ter
entradas de números complexos, alpha um a alpha n,
então a norma euclidiana de v é definida como você vê aqui.
Esta é a notação que
usamos para a norma euclidiana colocando essas barras duplas ao redor de qualquer vetor de que estamos falando.
Neste caso é v, e a forma como a norma euclidiana é definida é que é a raiz quadrada da soma
dos valores absolutos ao quadrado
das entradas do vetor.
Então outra forma de definir o que
é um vetor de estado quântico é que um vetor de estado quântico é um vetor coluna tendo
entradas de números complexos
cuja norma euclidiana é igual a um, o que quer dizer que é um vetor unitário com relação à norma euclidiana.
Isso é porque a soma
dos valores absolutos ao quadrado é igual a um se e somente se a norma euclidiana
é igual a um.
A raiz quadrada não muda nada quando a soma dos valores absolutos
ao quadrado é igual a um.
Então é isso que um vetor de estado quântico é. É um vetor coluna com índices que correspondem aos
estados clássicos de um sistema
tendo entradas de números complexos e norma euclidiana igual a um.
O que isso significa, ou o que isso implica, ou como devemos interpretar esta
noção é uma questão diferente e, em certo sentido,
o estudo da informação e computação quântica é uma exploração do que
essa definição implica, pelo menos em termos de
processamento de informação.
Este é simplesmente o ponto de partida.
Como um aparte, deixa eu mencionar que há
outras chamadas normas além da norma euclidiana e esta notação aqui com as barras duplas
ao redor de um vetor nem sempre
significa a norma euclidiana.
Em diferentes contextos, esta notação pode referir
a uma norma diferente.
Por exemplo, a soma
dos valores absolutos sem quadrados ou raiz quadrada é uma norma diferente,
muitas vezes chamada de norma um. Há bastantes
normas diferentes, de fato.
Às vezes você verá
esta notação sendo usada com um subscrito após
o segundo conjunto de barras que fornece mais informações sobre qual norma estamos falando.
E quando fazemos isso, é bastante típico que o número dois como subscrito
significa a norma euclidiana.
Mas nesta série, sempre que tivermos um
vetor coluna como este, esta notação de barras duplas por si só
significa a norma euclidiana.
Aqui estão alguns exemplos
de vetores de estado quântico e esses vetores de estado quântico em particular são vetores de estado qubit,
o que significa que os
estados clássicos do nosso sistema são zero e um.
A palavra qubit é abreviação de bit quântico, que é realmente apenas um bit
que pode estar em um estado quântico.
Os primeiros dois exemplos são realmente simples. Os vetores de base padrão
ket zero e ket um são vetores de estado quântico.
São ambos vetores coluna, e os índices correspondem
aos estados clássicos zero e um, e as entradas desses
vetores são números complexos.
Para esses vetores em particular, as entradas são zero e um, que são números reais e, de fato, são inteiros, mas também são números complexos
que por acaso têm
parte imaginária igual a zero.
Cada vetor tem uma entrada igual a um e uma entrada igual a zero.
Então quando somamos os valores absolutos
das entradas, obtemos um nos dois casos.
Então as condições
necessárias para que esses vetores sejam vetores de estado quântico são satisfeitas.
Os dois próximos exemplos são estados qubit muito comumente encontrados chamados o estado plus e o estado minus.
São denotados como você
vê aqui na tela, seja com ket plus
ou ket minus assim, e são definidos como
você pode ver aqui.
Novamente, as entradas desses
vetores são números complexos. Desta vez, são ou mais um sobre raiz quadrada de dois, ou menos um sobre raiz quadrada de dois,
e quando somamos os
valores absolutos ao quadrado, obtemos 1/2 mais 1/2, que é um.
Aliás, colocar um
sinal de mais ou um sinal de menos dentro de um ket como este
pode parecer um pouco estranho porque esses não são estados clássicos
do nosso sistema,
mas esta notação é usada mesmo assim, e voltaremos a isso em um momento.
Mas por ora, em suma, podemos usar a notação de Dirac para colocar qualquer nome que quisermos para um vetor dentro de um ket.
O vetor não precisa ser
um vetor de base padrão quando usamos a notação de Dirac.
Aqui está um exemplo final de estado qubit
por ora.
É um vetor de estado quântico de um qubit que não tem um nome especial, e não é particularmente significativo.
As entradas desse vetor são um mais dois vezes i
sobre três e menos 2/3.
Esses são números complexos, e se você calcular os
valores absolutos ao quadrado dessas duas entradas, obterá 5/9 para a primeira
e 4/9 para a segunda. Então a soma do valor absoluto
ao quadrado é igual a um.
E aqui está um último exemplo. Desta vez para um sistema
cujos estados clássicos são os quatro naipes de cartas.
Não sei por que teríamos um sistema cujos estados clássicos
são os quatro naipes de cartas estando em um estado quântico, mas é possível em princípio
e é apenas um exemplo.
As entradas correspondentes
aos diferentes naipes são 1/2 para paus, menos
i sobre dois para ouros,
zero para copas porque não aparece na soma e um sobre a raiz
quadrada de dois para espadas.
E aqui está como
fica como vetor coluna, assumindo que ordenamos
os estados clássicos como fizemos antes,
que é a ordem que
você vê aqui.
Tomar o valor absoluto
ao quadrado dessas entradas dá um quarto para a primeira, também um quarto para a próxima.
O valor absoluto ao quadrado
de zero é igual a zero, então essa entrada não
contribui para a soma.
E finalmente, para a última, obtemos 1/2. Então a soma é igual a um, como é necessário para que este vetor
seja um vetor de estado quântico.
Agora, há um momento atrás, usamos a notação
ket plus e ket minus para nos referir a dois vetores de estado qubit que não são vetores de base padrão.
E gostaria de voltar
a este ponto brevemente e explicar como a notação de Dirac é usada para vetores arbitrários e não apenas para vetores de base padrão.
Como já mencionei, podemos usar qualquer nome que
quisermos dentro de um bra ou ket para nos referir a um vetor.
Kets são vetores coluna
e bras são vetores linha, assim como antes.
Como exemplo, a letra grega
psi é muito comumente usada dentro de um ket para se referir a algum vetor arbitrário,
e aqui, estamos usando ela para
dar um nome ao vetor de estado de antes que não
tem um nome especial.
Quando fazemos isso, a letra psi não
necessariamente tem qualquer significado por si só.
É apenas o nome de um vetor, e está dentro de um ket para nos ajudar a esclarecer
que é um vetor coluna.
Isso pode ser um pouco
confuso às vezes, e há uma potencial ambiguidade se a letra psi pudesse ser associada
com um estado clássico de
algum sistema, por exemplo, mas geralmente não
causa nenhum problema, e você não precisa usar
a notação de Dirac assim
se não quiser. Usar uma letra minúscula como
u, v ou w sem um ket é também uma boa forma de
denotar um vetor coluna
ou, mais especificamente,
um vetor de estado quântico.
É sua escolha qual notação
usar para se expressar.
Você só precisa garantir
que, primeiro, o significado do que você
está tentando expressar seja claro para os outros.
E segundo, que você entenda o que
os outros estão tentando expressar mesmo quando suas preferências de notação não são as mesmas que as suas.
Há uma regra muito importante para usar a notação de Dirac
para vetores arbitrários e é que, se você tem um vetor coluna
que você decidiu escrever
como ket psi, por exemplo, ou poderia ser um
nome diferente dentro de um ket, então o vetor linha bra psi
é entendido como sendo
o transposto conjugado do vetor ket psi.
E aqui, isto é escrito como uma equação onde esta daga aqui se refere ao transposto conjugado.
O que é especificamente é
o vetor linha que você obtém, primeiro, transpondo o vetor, ou seja, virando o vetor de lado e mudando-o de uma coluna para uma linha
sem na verdade mudar as entradas. E segundo, tomando o conjugado complexo
de cada uma das entradas.
Na verdade, você pode realizar
essas duas operações, a transposição e o conjugado complexo entrada a entrada, em qualquer ordem, pois
essas duas operações comutam.
Então para o vetor neste exemplo, dado que decidimos
chamar este vetor de ket psi, entende-se que bra psi
significa este vetor aqui
onde transpusemos o vetor mudando ket zero e ket
um para bra zero e bra um, e tomamos o conjugado
complexo de cada entrada,
que é por que um mais
dois vezes i sobre três vira um menos dois
vezes i sobre três aqui.
Aqui está como esses vetores ficam quando escritos
explicitamente como vetor coluna e vetor linha.
Note, aliás, que
esta regra é consistente com a notação que usamos quando temos estados clássicos
dentro do bra e do ket.
Nesse caso, as entradas são
todas zero exceto por um 1, e então tomar o conjugado
complexo não faz nada nesse caso.
Já vimos como os estados quânticos são representados como vetores, mas não está claro neste
ponto qual é o significado ou as implicações
em termos do que você
pode fazer com o sistema em um estado quântico ou como você pode interagir com ele.
A primeira coisa que precisamos fazer para trazer essas questões ao foco
é discutir medições.
Intuitivamente falando,
medições fornecem um mecanismo para extrair informação clássica
de sistemas quânticos.
Quando olhamos para um sistema
quando está em um estado quântico, não vemos um estado quântico, assim como não vemos
estados probabilísticos,
vemos estados clássicos, e esta noção de medição é o que fornece a interface.
Se nós, como humanos, queremos saber algo sobre um sistema quântico, temos que medi-lo, e ao fazê-lo, vamos extrair informação clássica
sobre qualquer estado quântico
em que esse sistema estava.
Há diferentes
noções de medições. A diferença é realmente de generalidade, e vamos começar com a mais simples e básica,
que é tipicamente chamada de
medição de base padrão.
Vamos generalizar isso
em aulas subsequentes. Falaremos sobre as chamadas
medições projetivas na aula três, e depois mais tarde na
terceira unidade da série,
vamos falar sobre medições gerais, que também são chamadas de medidas de valor operador positivo, ou POVMs para abreviar.
Mas por ora, vamos restringir nossa atenção às medições de base padrão.
Quando uma medição é
realizada em um sistema, haverá algum conjunto
de possíveis resultados dessa medição, que são resultados clássicos,
e no caso de uma
medição de base padrão, esses possíveis resultados são
precisamente os estados clássicos de qualquer sistema que esteja sendo medido.
Cada um desses estados clássicos será o resultado da medição com alguma probabilidade, e essa probabilidade é o valor absoluto ao quadrado
da entrada correspondente
a esse estado clássico de qualquer vetor de estado quântico
em que o sistema estava imediatamente antes de ser medido.
Sabemos que o valor absoluto ao quadrado de qualquer número complexo é um número real não negativo, e sabemos pela definição
de vetores de estado quântico
que a soma do valor absoluto
ao quadrado das entradas de um vetor de estado quântico é igual a um.
Então isso faz sentido. Cada estado clássico aparecerá como o resultado da
medição com alguma probabilidade e as probabilidades somam um.
Aqui estão alguns exemplos. Primeiro, suponha que temos um
qubit no estado plus.
Se medirmos este qubit com relação a uma medição de base padrão, obtemos zero ou
um como resultado.
A probabilidade de obter zero é o valor absoluto
ao quadrado de um sobre raiz de dois, que é 1/2, e essa é a mesma
probabilidade de obter um.
Então se você medir um estado plus, obterá um bit aleatório uniforme.
Se o sistema está em um estado minus
em vez de um estado plus, então a medição funciona da
mesma forma.
As probabilidades são, novamente, 1/2 para cada resultado possível.
A única diferença aqui é que o sinal de mais virou um sinal de menos, mas quando tomamos o valor
absoluto, nada muda.
Se medirmos este estado qubit, a probabilidade de obter o resultado zero é o valor absoluto ao quadrado de um mais dois vezes i
sobre três, que é 5/9,
e a probabilidade de obter o resultado um é o valor absoluto ao quadrado
de menos 2/3, que é 4/9.
E finalmente, medir
o estado de base padrão, ket zero, dá o resultado
zero com certeza, e da mesma forma, medir o estado ket um
produz o resultado um com certeza. Isso é porque o valor
absoluto ao quadrado de um é um.
Similar ao que tínhamos no
contexto probabilístico. Podemos associar esses estados quânticos, ket zero e ket um, com o sistema estando naqueles estados clássicos,
e este exemplo é consistente
com essa interpretação.
Agora, assim como tínhamos no
contexto probabilístico, se medirmos um sistema quando
está em um estado quântico,
então o estado vai mudar, em geral, como resultado de ter
realizado essa medição.
Em particular, e novamente, isso é exatamente como tínhamos
no contexto probabilístico.
Se medirmos um sistema e o resultado da medição
é o estado clássico a, então o novo estado quântico
do sistema se torna ket a.
Então para este estado aqui, por exemplo, vemos o mesmo tipo
de comportamento que tínhamos no contexto probabilístico.
Se medirmos, então com probabilidade 5/9, obtemos o resultado zero, caso em que o estado
faz a transição para ket zero,
e com probabilidade
4/9, o resultado é um, e o estado faz a transição para ket um.
Às vezes esse fenômeno é referido como o colapso
do estado quântico, e é o tipo de
coisa que mantém as pessoas
que estudam os fundamentos
da mecânica quântica acordadas à noite.
Mas de uma perspectiva puramente
matemática, é realmente bastante simples
e muito análogo ao que temos no caso probabilístico.
A fonte de tensão aqui, em certo sentido, diz respeito à natureza fundamental dos estados quânticos e ao que eles representam
e como diferem
de estados probabilísticos. Mas em nível matemático, isso é talvez o que você esperaria.
Note, aliás, que se
você medisse uma segunda vez, então obteria exatamente
o mesmo resultado que obteve para a primeira medição.
Então há um limite de quanta
informação clássica pode ser extraída de um estado quântico, e voltaremos a este ponto em breve
em outra aula. Falamos sobre estados quânticos bem como medições, especificamente medições de base padrão,
que fornecem uma forma de
extrair informação clássica de estados quânticos.
O tópico restante para
esta aula é operações, especificamente operações unitárias, que descrevem como
os estados quânticos dos sistemas
podem ser alterados. Naturalmente, dado que
os vetores de estado quântico são diferentes dos vetores de probabilidade, seria de esperar que o conjunto
de operações permitidas
em estados quânticos seja diferente do que temos para
a informação clássica, e de fato, esse é o caso.
Enquanto operações em estados probabilísticos são representadas por matrizes estocásticas, operações em vetores de estado quântico
são representadas por matrizes unitárias.
Aqui está a definição de matrizes unitárias.
Uma matriz quadrada U tendo
entradas de números complexos é unitária se satisfaz as igualdades
que você vê aqui.
A daga representa
o transposto conjugado, que já vimos para vetores quando falamos sobre a
notação de Dirac há alguns momentos.
Aqui estamos realizando o
transposto conjugado em uma matriz em vez de um vetor, mas é essencialmente a mesma coisa.
Transpomos a matriz, o que apenas significa que
trocamos linhas e colunas, então a entrada JK se torna a entrada KJ,
e também tomamos o conjugado
complexo de cada entrada.
Além disso, esta notação aqui
significa a matriz identidade.
Essas duas igualdades aqui
são na verdade equivalentes. Se você tem uma, então
automaticamente tem a outra.
Ambas são equivalentes a
dizer que U é invertível e o inverso é igual
ao transposto conjugado.
Isso é verdade apenas para matrizes quadradas,
aliás. Se você tem uma matriz que não é quadrada, então uma dessas duas
igualdades pode ser verdadeira,
mas então a outra não será verdadeira.
Mas aqui, estamos falando
de matrizes quadradas.
Então esta é a definição padrão
para matrizes unitárias, e é boa porque é fácil verificar
se uma matriz é unitária.
Você simplesmente multiplica a matriz pelo seu transposto conjugado em ambos os lados, e verifica se obtém
a matriz identidade.
Há uma forma equivalente de caracterizar matrizes unitárias, e é que uma
matriz quadrada é unitária se e somente se ela nunca
muda a norma euclidiana
de qualquer vetor quando você multiplica. Uma matriz N por N U é unitária se e somente se a
norma euclidiana de U vezes v
é igual à norma euclidiana de v para todo vetor coluna n-dimensional v com entradas de números complexos.
E portanto, se v é
um vetor de estado quântico, então U vezes v também é
um vetor de estado quântico, porque vetores de estado quântico
são simplesmente os vetores com
norma euclidiana igual a um.
Na verdade, podemos dizer um pouco mais, que é que as matrizes unitárias são precisamente as matrizes que sempre transformam
vetores de estado quântico
em vetores de estado quântico. Isso é uma situação similar ao que temos para matrizes estocásticas
e vetores de probabilidade.
As matrizes estocásticas
são precisamente as matrizes que sempre transformam vetores de probabilidade em vetores de probabilidade.
Então, uma vez que decidimos que as operações devem ser representadas por matrizes, o que é o mesmo que dizer que as transformações agem linearmente
nos vetores que representam estados, essas escolhas para os conjuntos
de operações permitidas seguem naturalmente, pelo menos
em um sentido matemático.
Agora vamos dar uma olhada em alguns exemplos de operações unitárias qubit.
Veremos muitos mais exemplos
de operações unitárias em aulas subsequentes, incluindo operações unitárias em sistemas
com mais de dois estados clássicos. Mas por ora, vamos nos concentrar apenas
em operações unitárias qubit.
Vamos continuar vendo esses
exemplos em particular surgindo repetidamente, então definitivamente vale a pena
conhecer essas operações.
A primeira coleção de exemplos são as chamadas operações de Pauli.
Essas são as operações que correspondem às matrizes de Pauli, que são mostradas aqui.
Todas são unitárias, e você pode verificar isso para cada uma de acordo com a definição de antes.
Essas matrizes em particular
por acaso são iguais aos seus próprios transpostos conjugados, o que quer dizer que elas são
todas matrizes hermitianas.
Então verificar que elas são
todas unitárias, neste caso, é uma questão de elevar cada uma ao quadrado e ver que o resultado
é a matriz identidade.
Os nomes que você vê para essas
matrizes são bastante padrão, e você também verá sigma
x, sigma y e sigma z chamadas simplesmente de X, Y e Z.
Esteja ciente, no entanto, de que as
letras maiúsculas X, Y e Z também são comumente usadas para outros fins, mesmo no contexto de
informação quântica,
mas são nomes muito comuns
para essas matrizes.
A operação sigma x ou X
também é chamada de inversão de bit ou operação NOT, que já vimos
no contexto clássico.
E a operação sigma z ou Z
também é chamada de inversão de fase.
E aqui, você pode ver a
ação dessas operações nos vetores de base padrão, o que meio que explica
de onde esses nomes vêm.
Certamente faz sentido
referir-se a sigma x como inversão de bit com base nesta ação aqui.
Ela simplesmente inverte o bit de
zero para um ou um para zero.
Também faz sentido
chamar sigma z de inversão de fase com base nesta ação aqui.
Mas se isso não estiver cristalino
no momento, tudo bem.
Vamos encontrar essa
operação repetidamente e a importância
de colocar um sinal de menos na frente do vetor de base ket um e não ket zero
e por que isso é chamado de inversão de fase ficará mais claro depois.
O próximo exemplo é
a operação Hadamard, que é representada por
esta matriz aqui, que é quase sempre chamada de H.
Verificar que H é unitária é novamente um
cálculo simples, que se eu sair do caminho, você pode ver aqui.
Similar às matrizes de Pauli, H é seu próprio transposto conjugado.
Então temos esta igualdade aqui, e quando realizamos a multiplicação, obtemos a matriz identidade como é necessário.
O terceiro exemplo é
na verdade uma classe inteira de operações unitárias
conhecidas como operações de fase.
Essas são operações
representadas por qualquer matriz que assume esta forma
que você vê aqui, onde theta é qualquer número real.
Então esta entrada aqui sempre será algum número complexo no círculo unitário.
Matrizes como esta são sempre unitárias, o que deixarei para você verificar.
Desta vez, o transposto conjugado não será igual à matriz original, a menos que este número aqui por acaso
seja um ou um menos um,
caso em que acabamos com
ou a matriz identidade ou sigma z, que já
encontramos.
Especificamente, a transposição
não fará nada com esta matriz, mas tomar o conjugado
complexo de cada entrada muda esta entrada aqui
para e à potência menos i theta.
Essas duas operações em particular aqui são exemplos particularmente importantes de operações de fase.
Para a primeira, tomamos
theta igual a pi sobre dois, e obtemos esta matriz aqui.
Esta é comumente chamada de
operação S ou S gate quando falamos de circuits, que não discutiremos nesta aula,
mas é um tópico importante
que está chegando em breve.
A segunda é esta operação. É uma operação T ou T gate.
E para esta, theta
é igual a pi sobre quatro. E então quando calculamos a exponencial, obtemos este valor aqui, que é um mais i sobre
a raiz quadrada de dois.
Aqui estão apenas alguns exemplos rápidos para ver algumas dessas
operações em ação.
Aqui está a ação da
operação Hadamard em ket zero e ket um.
Se fizermos a
multiplicação matriz-vetor, vemos que o que obtemos são o estado plus e o
estado minus, respectivamente.
Se realizarmos a operação Hadamard no estado plus e no
estado minus, por outro lado, voltamos para ket zero e ket um.
Então se organizarmos as coisas um pouco, podemos ver a ação mais claramente.
A operação Hadamard
transforma de um lado para o outro entre o estado zero e o estado plus e entre o estado um
e o estado minus.
Sobre essas duas equações aqui, note que isso nos dá uma forma simples de detectar a diferença entre um estado plus e um estado minus.
Como vimos mais cedo na aula, se medirmos um estado plus
e um estado minus com relação à medição de base padrão,
obtemos um bit aleatório uniforme em ambos os casos, o que não nos ajuda a
detectar a diferença.
Mas se realizarmos uma operação Hadamard e depois medirmos, veremos um zero se o
estado original era um estado plus
e um se o estado original
era um estado minus.
Então esses dois estados são de fato diferentes, e eles podem ser discriminados
perfeitamente pelo método que acabei de descrever,
que é primeiro realizar
uma operação Hadamard e depois medir.
Voltando ao exemplo de
um estado qubit que vimos antes que não é particularmente especial, podemos ver o que a operação Hadamard
faz com o estado
convertendo para as formas
que você vê aqui e realizando a multiplicação.
E aqui está o resultado
que podemos converter de volta para a notação de Dirac se quisermos,
e essa é uma forma de calcular
esses tipos de ações.
Aqui está outro exemplo que ilustra que você nem sempre
precisa converter explicitamente para uma forma de vetor de matriz.
Você também pode realizar essas
computações diretamente usando a notação de Dirac.
Este exemplo diz respeito à operação T, e aqui está
apenas para referência.
Esta operação tem esta ação aqui em estados de base padrão.
E se quisermos calcular
a ação da operação T em um estado plus, por exemplo, podemos começar expandindo a
definição do estado plus
e então usar a linearidade
para expressar o resultado como você vê aqui.
Podemos agora simplesmente inserir
essas expressões aqui em cima, fazer apenas um pouco de
simplificação para o segundo termo, e obtemos o resultado.
Se por qualquer razão quisermos aplicar uma operação Hadamard
ao resultado, podemos fazer uma coisa similar.
Primeiro, substituímos a expressão de T agindo no estado plus e usamos a linearidade como fizemos antes.
E agora, se substituirmos as
expressões que já temos para a operação Hadamard
agindo em ket zero e ket um,
obtemos isso. E agora, podemos expandir o estado plus e o estado minus para obter esta expressão aqui,
que podemos simplificar apenas somando, e aqui está o resultado final.
Não há nada de particularmente
especial sobre este exemplo. Ele apenas visa
ilustrar esta forma alternativa mas equivalente de
calcular as ações
dessas operações. Você pode usar qualquer
forma que seja mais conveniente na situação em questão.
Um último ponto sobre
operações unitárias é que composições de operações unitárias são representadas por multiplicação de matrizes
assim como no contexto probabilístico, ou seja, você pode calcular a ação de uma sequência de operações unitárias
simplesmente multiplicando
as matrizes juntas. E o que você obterá é
uma única matriz unitária representando a ação combinada
da sequência de operações.
Assim como tínhamos para matrizes estocásticas, as matrizes unitárias são
fechadas sob multiplicação, então você sempre obterá uma matriz unitária
quando compuser operações unitárias.
Você precisa ter certeza
de que multiplica as matrizes na ordem correta.
Mas a forma como funciona é exatamente como era para
operações estocásticas, onde a matriz para a
primeira operação que você realiza
sempre aparecerá no lado direito
do produto de matrizes, e a última aparecerá
no lado esquerdo.
Então, assim como antes, a ordem é invertida no sentido de que você compõe da direita para a esquerda em vez de da esquerda para a direita.
Aqui está um exemplo interessante que dá origem a uma operação conhecida como a operação raiz quadrada de NOT.
Suponha que primeiro
aplicamos uma operação Hadamard seguida de uma operação S, seguida de outra operação Hadamard.
A ação combinada de
essas três operações é descrita por este produto.
Aqui está a primeira operação Hadamard, aqui está a operação S, e aqui está a segunda operação Hadamard.
Se realizarmos a multiplicação de matrizes, que não é mostrada explicitamente aqui, mas você pode fazer isso por
conta própria se quiser,
o resultado é esta matriz aqui. É uma matriz unitária, e podemos verificar isso diretamente
ou podemos confiar no fato de que as matrizes unitárias são
fechadas sob multiplicação.
Ela tem que ser unitária porque essas três matrizes são unitárias, como já vimos.
Não temos nenhum vetor de estado quântico
específico em mente aqui.
Podemos imaginar realizar
esta sequência de operações em qualquer vetor de estado quântico, e esta matriz descreve a ação.
O motivo pelo qual esta operação combinada, ou seja, a descrita
por esta matriz aqui, é chamada de operação raiz quadrada de NOT,
é que ao realizá-la
duas vezes, obtemos uma operação NOT, ou em outras palavras, uma
operação sigma x ou X.
Realizar a operação
duas vezes é representado por elevar a matriz ao quadrado, ou seja,
multiplicá-la por ela mesma.
E se você fizer isso, verá que o resultado
é a matriz Pauli x.
E isso é meio peculiar, e te dá apenas uma sugestão de que você pode fazer algumas coisas interessantes com informação quântica que não pode fazer com
informação clássica.
Não há nenhuma operação clássica, ou seja, uma representada
por uma matriz estocástica, que nos dá uma operação NOT
se a realizarmos duas vezes.
Então é um bom exemplo que revela que operações quânticas
se comportam de forma muito diferente de operações clássicas.
E isso é tudo para a aula um. Nesta aula, discutimos como a informação quântica funciona para sistemas simples em isolamento,
e na próxima aula, vamos falar sobre como
a informação quântica funciona para múltiplos sistemas.
Obrigado por assistir. Se tiver alguma dúvida, sinta-se à vontade para deixá-la na
seção de comentários abaixo.